wollt ihr dass ich mal sonne soll real
life dass ich so jeden tag so ein
reallife video hochladen
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer runde ender
games auf dem komma hd.de server ich
spiele als yeti es leckt ungemein sonst
leicht hat nämlich jetzt gerade schon
nicht ausgefeilt ich hab gerade schon
zwei runden gespielt wo ich zwei mal
wegen ein bug gestorben weil ich in so
einem baum fest gesunken war
auf einmal runter gefallen aber danach
war ich tot aber ich hab gedacht ich
mach das jetzt hier nochmal weil ich
mich umbenannt habe das ganz cool ich
spiele den yeti der kann irgendwie so
über wasser laufen mit seiner schnee
spur die vögel sind sehr laut ich wenn
die nachher unterstellen aber für mich
grad sehr lang und ich glaube ich werde
mich gleich heftig erschrecken und es
lag schon wieder bei mir und ich hasse
es ich dachte er hätte die neue server
gekauft der böse komme aber es liegt
einfach ungemein bei mir das liegt
irgendwie im internet gerade aber naja
muss man jetzt mit leben ich hole mir
erst mal wie viel holz und zwar mache
ich dieses video war ich so ein bisschen
darüber reden wollte warum genau noch
mal keine videos in der letzten zeit
kamen und wie das genau der zukunft
ablaufen wird mit dem neuen microsoft
project und auch mit reallife videos und
mit projekten allgemein wo ich sehr
stolz auf euch angewiesen bin bzw
das ganze mit euch
mehr oder weniger planen möchte so ich
muss jetzt erstmal irgendwie ein paar
kisten finden weil hier sonst gar nichts
laufen wird ich bis 15 sekunden noch
keine kiste mit alten gefunden habe dann
mache ich mir einfach eben irgendetwas
mit mach das schon das ende macht mir
einfach eben irgendwas mit holz oder so
harvey nach dienstende ist egal
ich fange einfach gleich an wenn ich
erst mal ein bisschen der krippen zack
zack da mach ich mir jetzt erstmal eine
spitzhacke und dann noch das erst mal
gucken ob er einer ist keiner jetzt ich
weiß gar nicht ging das geht das
überhaupt gemacht dass ich hier steine
abgebaut habe auch mano steinchen u bahn
scheint tipp möchte ich dass er zu mir
kommt so ich geh mal einfach hier unten
rein wenn mich jetzt eine angriff wehren
ich mir jetzt hier gerade der mannschaft
mache dann hole ich aber so aber ich
nehme die ganze zeit denke ich mal dass
stein schwert in der hand damit keiner
irgendwie so denkt zu der diamant
schwert 860 profumo jetzt will ich die
schüler weg porte das echt so kratz in
diesem spiel man will einfach so ja du
bist zwar karten sterne und daraus hat
der boxing gestellt aber wir brauchen
dich weg beste automarke wenn ich jetzt
im wasserspringen wenn ich direkt zu
halbtot okay auch das fand das wort
spricht wieder voll komisch nee also um
auf das thema zu sprechen zu kommen was
ich vorhin schon eingesetzt habe warum
genau keine videos kam hat einfach den
simplen grund dass ich einfach wirklich
keine zeit hatte ich habe gestern schon
so ein bisschen sagt möchte es jetzt
eigentlich noch mal so ein bisschen
ausführlicher machen obwohl es
eigentlich gar nicht ausführlicher geht
es waren halt immer so ein paar sachen
die da so dazwischen gekommen sind wenn
ich so gerade ich sag mal zeit hatte ein
video aufzunehmen dann kamen so spontan
wieder was anderes oder nicht mal
spontan sondern auch manchmal so einfach
ja okay ich könnte jetzt ein video
aufnehmen aber
schlafen wird mir jetzt einfach so gut
tun so abends um elf uhr oder so
deswegen kann man da manchmal einfach
kein video ich weiß nicht vielleicht
besiegte ich den oder soll er hat humor
aber passiert der in der physik mich
locker der hartenstein schwert und
jajaja geil hat er stark gemacht das
muss man sagen das war echt gut ich
soeben eine neue lobby und geht dann da
oben rein und zockt an das so dann gebe
ich mir noch eben der yeti eigentlich
eine ganz coole klasse jetzt läuft auch
ein bisschen flüssiger muss man sagen ja
jetzt läuft so es war wirklich einfach
mal manchmal so dass ich um 10 uhr erst
zu hause war und dann einfach die
knochen
man konnte beim austria video james
gestern wieder gemacht jetzt bei geraten
video
ich hatte halt manchmal einfach so
phasen während dieser zeit wo ich
richtig bock auf auf dem hatte aber dann
einfach so gesagt hab ich könnte jetzt
aufnehmen aber ich könnte auch einfach
jetzt mit freunden was unternehmen weil
ich den ganzen damit auch schon gelernt
habe oder so und dann möchte man einfach
nicht sich dann noch mal bei guten
wetter hinsetzen teilweise wasser hier
25 grad oder so weh da wollte man dann
einfach nicht hier vom computer sitzt
und eine stunde auf gehen und das dann
schneiden und hochladen es dauert ja
locker vier stunden bei meinem internet
und bei meinem rechner hier das ganze zu
bearbeiten rändern exportieren et cetera
sondern da möchte man einfach etwas mit
freunden machen oder dann irgendwie zeit
mit den freunden verbringen oder
irgendwas anderes machen oder irgendwo
hinfahren oder halt einfach dann abends
schlafen anstatt dann irgendwie noch vom
pc zu setzen videos zu drehen also es
hat echt gut getan einfach mal so zwei
monate ganz wenig zu machen ich habe
zwischendurch ein projekt mit gombe
gemacht wo ich mir dann gesagt habe okay
danach kommen wieder videos aber dann
habe ich ihn nie wieder so eine pause
gemacht wo ich dann wirklich weil sie
nicht also ich hatte nicht mal seinen
großen stress aber es war wichtig
einfach so ich saß hier vom pc und das
ist auch ganz komisch gewesen ich hatte
wirklich manchmal so dieses gefühl
ich hatte angst davor auf meinem youtube
kanal zu gehen und mir die kommentare
durchzulesen
weil da so viele leute einfach um
geredet haben so von wegen immer wieder
videos was sollen das so voll arroganter
denkst du musst keine videos mehr machen
richtig doof alter obwohl keiner
verstanden hat wirklich wo weil keiner
so wirklich genau verstanden warum ich
wirklich keine jetzt habe ich wieder
nichts bekommen wegen diesen ganzen lexi
warum ich wirklich keine videos gemacht
also das war alles ein bisschen doof
mehr oder weniger sache weiß dass ich
mir jetzt einfach den beschluss gefasst
hat okay ich fange ich wieder an videos
machen weil jetzt das neue projekt
minecraft ich sag den damalig darf ich
andere gar nicht kommt bald ein trailer
zu da fängt bald ein neues projekt an
das wird sehr geil ich weiß nicht was
ich dazu schon alles sagen darf ich halt
einfach mal meine fresse es wird auf
jeden fall heftig geil
es wurden schon ich sage jetzt einfach
mal das ist ja auch nicht schlimm
es wurden schon sachen in diesem projekt
aufgenommen allerdings noch nicht
hochgeladen
also das wird jetzt ist er wieder da vor
mir an der kiste bestimmt schon die
heftigsten sachen jetzt glaubte mir
bestimmt noch das holz erspart die es
wird auf jeden fall heftig geil das kann
ich schon mal sagen es wird auch noch
einen schweren weg
ein trader rauskommen ich hoffe ich hab
noch nicht zu viel verraten sonst
erfahrt ihr das bei mir jede special
dies das und ich würde einfach sagen ich
jetzt mal ein bisschen durch ist ob die
runde wird richtig kag und ich werde
direkt jetzt gleich sterben
der spieler hinweg 20 verbleibenden
spieler ich bin auf jeden fall schon mal
nicht der schlechteste
es wird auf jeden fall heftig geil aber
was ja er hat ein altes schwert das ist
geil das ist gut habe die direkt wieder
tot das natürlich klasse was soll ich
noch machen man geil sei aber immer noch
fast hier lief eigentlich wollte ich
möchte eigentlich am liebsten einfach
ein bisschen die reden so ich will hier
die spieler anzeigen kann ich den
spieler wie allen zeigen
da sind wir gar keine spieler lobby oder
sehe ich dir einfach gar nicht es war
einfach so dass viele sachen dazwischen
gekommen sind so die eigentlich
teilweise geplant waren aber teilweise
auch einfach so spontan und wo ich mir
gesagt haben ich kann gerade so viel
bessere sachen machen als video zu
drehen
das war nicht so dass ich in die andere
sachen über euch gestellt höhe die sind
sich würdig ein video zu bekommen da
gehe ich lieber was mit meinen freunden
unternehmen sondern einfach so ich bin
ko oder vorname ist folglich danach
zumute und dann sonst hätte ich einfach
gesetzt und ja ich mache jetzt die zetas
oder hätte ich auch halt einfach selber
auch keinen bock drauf gehabt der die
auch selbst keinen bock drauf gehabt
dass zuzuschauen
aber die sache ist halt ein paar sachen
die dazwischen gekommen sind kann jemals
beispiel denn wir haben beispielsweise
ich war mit zwei freunden in dortmund
und wir haben dort einen film gedreht
für seinen film wettbewerb und den film
gibt es auch online einzusehen da kann
man auch glaube ich abstimmen also wenn
ihr das wollt könnt ihr da sogar glaub
ich abstimmen ich weiß ich glaube das
kann jeder also ich glaube man muss
nicht mehr registriert sein ich kann
euch das wenn jeder interessierte an
seit die server von diesem film
hochladen kacke dingsbums sind deftig
scheiß also wahrscheinlich wird das
einstürzen wenn da mehr als zehn leute
drauf sind
also wir haben zum beispiel einen film
gedreht da könnt ihr zum beispiel sehen
was wir gemacht haben obdachlosen
geholfen und den so was zu essen gegeben
so dass wir schon bei youtube das
herkommen können eigentlich auch und so
das war thema traum
und andere an irgendwas mit träumen
gemacht so von wegen jahren im traum
kann man alles verwirklichen wir haben
so gesagt ja wir haben darauf in einer
besseren welt selbstverständlich meine
da aber nähern
daher wollte nur seinen kleinen sozialen
aspekt aber drei bringen doch lose
leuten geholfen
aber es ist auf jeden fall das muss man
echt sagen es war heftig geile erfahrung
und man hat sich richtig gut dabei
gefühlt wenn man diesen obdachlosen
diese tüte geschenkt hat also werden so
tüten mit lebensmittel gekauft hatten
den obdachlosen geschenkt und dann hat
sich echt gut dabei gefühlt aber egal
wenn ihr das sehen wollt dann klickt
einfach auf den link in der beschreibung
da könnt ihr dann euch das ganze
anschauen und auch abstimmen mit fünf
sternen bewerten das wäre auf jeden fall
heftig cool wenn ihr das bewerten würde
stimmt das dass china das können ja
eigentlich also wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr
werdet euch gefällt sonst gibt es ein
stern oder so dann aber naja wir auf
jeden fall killer und sonst
fast noch das gibt es ja noch ein
beispiel zum beispiel die konzerte
geplant
weil wir ein ganzes wochenende wohl ich
eigentlich immer nur am wochenende
aufnehmen wochenende in der schule also
wirklich von sonntagmorgens 10 uhr bis
sonntagabend 13 23 uhr hat dafür dann am
montag die ersten stunde teilweise frei
bekommen weil wir so lange schule waren
das war heftig krass aber das konzert
war richtig cool
da müssen jetzt auch den abiball plan
und alles mögliche und die vor wie klose
da will ich gar nicht mehr von anfang wo
ich wirklich deutsch teilweise heftig
viel gelernt habe ich hab ne 2 bekommen
also geht schon einigermaßen aber ich
habe echt heftig trust gelernt für alle
möglichen sachen und ja es waren halt
echt mal so ein paar sachen die dann
halt einfach dazwischen gekommen sind
ich hätte es locker geschafft doch
videos zu produzieren
irgendwie allerdings dann abends um zehn
uhr oder in zwei freistunden alle tasten
hallo
das geht laut christie 22 hallo und er
war auf jeden fall eine schöne zeit
möchte ich sogar einfach mal sagen wo
ich einfach mal so entspannen konnte
dann nach dem ganzen stressigen jetzt wo
ich auch eine woche keine videos gemacht
hat obwohl ich zeit hatte
aber ich hoffe einfach akzeptiert meine
entscheiden lasse sich eine kleine pause
gegönnt habe jetzt geht es wieder los in
ein paar tagen startet auch das neue
projekt und was ich auch sagen wollte
noch zum abschluss
wollt ihr dass ich mal so soll real life
dass ich so jeden tag zu einem reallife
video hochladen
wollt ihr dass das ich so einfach
irgendwie was ich mache also es kann
sein dass ich das dann einfach ich habe
jetzt ja erst mal ein paar monate frei
bis zu meinem studium beziehungsweise
bis zum abitur dass ich da einfach mal
so ein paar sachen aufnehmen wenn ich
zum beispiel einer waschstraße sitze so
zwei minuten oder wenn ich
beispielsweise gerade mal am essen bin
wenn ich irgendwo einer großstadt bin
oder so fünf minuten lang so einfach
irgendwann video so jeden tag so wollt
ihr sowas haben sondern zum kalender ist
ob kraft das gemacht lena hat das so in
der weihnachtszeit gemacht ich dachte
einfach so einfach mal so ob ihr das
wollt schreibt einfach dein kommentar
ist dann video was dann halt immer so
abends kommt zu gegen 10 uhr oder 9 08
uhr sowie um den dreh und wenn ihr das
wollt dann sagst mir einfach schreibt
zudem kommentare ist immer so wenn
irgendwas wollte und es wäre auch ganz
cool wenn ihr mir einfach schreiben
würde die anuga ich will dass du mal
diesem modus des spiels server oder
mafia oder oder irgendwann ganz anderes
spiel was sich maletz plänen soll
beziehungsweise einfach so als place
macht ja nicht einfach so videos davon
hochladen soll irgendeine handy app kann
ja auch sein schreibt mir die kommentare
und viel zu viel gelabert viel zu wenig
gespielt wird in den nächsten videos
besser
ich würde einfach sein wenn euch
gefallen hat wenn es euch trotzdem
gefallen hat lasst mir wert oder ihr
könnt einfach in die beschreibung gucken
da ist der film verlinkt glaube ich
hoffe ich kann hier draufklicken könne
bewerten können euch angucken wenn die
server damit halten
und sonst ich sage noch einer schönen
tag und tschüss